pour les scientifiques de nouveautés la
maîtrise d'électrotechnique et la
maîtrise d'électro chili appliquée pour
les étudiants en droit mise en place vu
le mst maîtrise des sciences et
techniques comptables et financières
pour l'éviter rers de nouveautés de la
maîtrise des langues étrangères
appliquées mention affaires et commerces
et la maîtrise de français en tant que
langue étrangère les universitaires ont
le souci de donner à leurs étudiants
un socle de connaissances extrêmement
solide c'est d'ailleurs aussi le souci
des milieux professionnels et nous
souhaitons aussi donner à nos étudiants
le maximum de chances de trouver un
débouché est un problème important à
l'heure actuelle donc ce que nous avons
essayé de mettre en place c'est à côté
de chaque filière traditionnelle donnant
le socle de connaissances que tout le
monde connaît disons de mettre en place
montrent des filières professionnelles
qui prépare nos étudiants à un métier de
façon plus nette que ces anciennes
formations 38 des sciences il faut
préparer cette maîtrise
d'électrotechnique
elle remplace l'ancienne licence de
physique trop générales une fois formés
et diplômés ces étudiants seront aptes à
aider les entreprises qui se tournent
vers l'informatique et la robotisation
de leurs services les besoins régionaux
pour le thème poste sans importance
puisque c'est toute l'industrie liée à
la microtechnique qui est en train de se
reconvertir
quant à la nouvelle maîtrise de chimie a
conduit directement au domaine de la
protection des surfaces
c'est également à la demande des milieux
professionnels concernés que ces
étudiants en droit ou sciences
économiques
ils sont une trentaine se voient
proposer l'accès direct au métier
d'expert comptable par voie
universitaire avec cette nouvelle
maîtrise de comptabilité et finance ils
seront dans deux ans
qualifié pour s'occuper de la trésorerie
des entreprises est resté vain donc
assurer le recrutement des experts
comptables dans les années qui viennent
puisque jusqu'à présent
ce recrutement se faisait d'une manière
non suivi les gens travailler deux
seules soit le soir le week-end
n'étaient pas encadrés par du personnel
dont seniors est un grand atout pour les
professionnels pour les professionnels
oui pour la
les conduire profession expert comptable
c'est très prisé puisque pour assurer le
recrutement des professeurs des
experts-comptables n'y aura rien d'autre
vous allez peut être pas l'impression
que ça va vous aider à trouver
directement et 80 travail bah oui dans
la mesure où on aura des jeunes
formations à mon avis beaucoup plus
complète et dans la mesure où ceux-ci
que les insérer dans une formation de
vision qui prépara l'expertise-comptable
va être reconnu beaucoup plus que
l'ancien dsi s est donc au niveau du
marché du travail je pense que nous
aurons une très bonne insertion dans le
domaine des langues étrangères
appliquées la nouvelle maîtrise à
vocation professionnelle est bilingue
anglais allemand ou italien
avec une mention à faire et commerces en
relation avec la chambre de commerce
pour les débouchés la fac de lettres
prépare les étudiants bilingues aux
métiers du tourisme de l'exportation du
marketing de la traduction
quant au cla il propose désormais une
licence de france est réservé aux
étrangers qui se prépare à enseigner les
années précédentes on a toujours des
conventions v que l'université de lyon 2
par exemple
mais le fait d'avoir une habilitation de
garantie de pouvoir continuer les études
à besançon où est de ne pas être obligé
de changer à la fois d'une année voire
en cours d'année si la convention poser
les problèmes d'accord avec l'autre
universités c'est toujours important que
vont rester de sa région parce que ça
signifie pour les étudiants qui vont
choisir ces nouvelles filières un métier
assuré au bout de leurs études
donc ça nous être très prudent dans ce
domaine métier assuré si vous voulez me
faire dire que nous avons des
engagements des entreprises de dix ans
nous vous prenons tant d'étudiants dans
deux ans je suis bien obligé de vous
répondre non les entreprises
aucune entreprise leur acteur ne peut
prendre ce style d'engagement par contre
nous avons
l'assurance des milieux professionnels
qu'il y a des besoins dans ce domaine
dans le même esprit l'université de
besançon ouvrir l'an prochain de
nouvelles filières la première à la
faculté des sciences
il s'agira d'un diplôme d'ingénieur
mathématicien préparer en cinq ans
aucune autre université française ne
propose encore ce diplôme seconde
filière en sciences économiques avec une
maîtrise spécialisée dans le commerce à
l'exportation